jean-vincent placé le président du
groupe écologiste au sénat est l'invité
de preuves par 3 public sénat afp
dailymotion bonsoir jean vincent placé
et merci d'être avec nous un pendant 45
minutes sans interruption
si celle des reportages le premier
portera sur les vos camarades militants
qui rêve d'une autre alliance vert rouge
dans la foulée de votre départ du
gouvernement et le second reportage sur
le sujet qui est faire en fait de vous
le grand allié de manuel valls
la fin annoncée des départements puisque
vous êtes son seul relais au sénat sur
ce sujet et également sur sa méthode
avec nous ce soir perrine tarneaud de
public sénat et jean luc prévost de l'
agence france-presse d'abord une
première question sur les risques de
guerre civile désormais au coeur même de
l'europe une fois de plus la dîmière
poutine agit à sa guise pour empêcher
l'ukraine de se tourner vers vers
l'europe comme est ce que vous voyez le
président et maîtres absolus russe le
problème du maître absolu russe secure
il est à la tête d'un état très puissant
très riche aujourd'hui et très
militarisée et donc le rapport de force
dans la zone est extrêmement sa faveur
moi j'ai évidemment suivi de très près
comme l'ensemble des passionnés de
l'europe la situation en ukraine je me
suis réjoui du retour de la démocratie
du fait qu' il ya un mouvement populaire
mais après il faut être quand même
extrêmement attentif à ce qui se passe
c'est à dire que la crimée on voit que
on a reculé assez rapidement ce scénario
la réalité aussi c'est que personne ne
s'est intéressé à ce qu'est par exemple
tout simplement l'armée ukrainienne qui
est totalement inexistante ce qui fait
que assez intelligemment dans son
optique
poutine avance ses pions vers le nième
prend fin c'est ça la réalité aussi bien
kharkiv que à donetsk suscitant des
mouvements et moi je suis extrêmement
inquiet par cette situation et autres ou
tout à la fois non mais moi je pense que
c'est une erreur de la part des
européens d'essayer d'en faire un
épouvantail idée ce qu'il est on peut le
qualifier de ce qu'on veut ça n'a
strictement pour le coup pour le
rayonnement du problème ukrainien aucun
intérêt tout simplement
que certes nous sommes assez actif et je
me réjouis d'action de certains avaient
été mises affaires étrangères de la zone
en particulier les allemands et les
polonais mais la réalité c'est que comme
personne évidemment selon une forme et
malheureusement daté mais bien connu
personne va mourir pour kiev
eh bien il faut trouver une solution
négociée et pour avoir une solution
négociée ça sert pas à grand chose de
faire le matamore en insultant si j'ose
dire le futur partenaire et qui n'est
pas encore un adversaire alors qu'en
fait ça n'a aucun des moyens militaires
ce qui d'ailleurs souligne un autre
sujet au delà de diplomatie et on
l'avait déjà dit notamment au moment de
la syrie c'est à dire la faiblesse de de
la défense européenne qu'il n'existe
enfin moi je ne suis pas militariste
vous le savez dans écologistes mémé tu
elle-même
il faut que tout de même que oui mais
attention une baisse de budget notamment
sur la question de la dissuasion
nucléaire mais moi j'ai toujours été
favorable à une force d'intervention qui
soit efficace et la voyez vous on n'a
plus beaucoup de soldats pour pouvoir
être actif donc on n'a pas beaucoup
d'arguments de rapports de force et donc
il faut arriver à une solution négociée
intelligente pour que monsieur poutine
se mettent autour de la table et aussi
les sujets d'ailleurs économique est
particulièrement fort sur énergétique
tout une question du gaz est ce qu'il
faudrait tout de suite passé au niveau
maximal des sanctions économiques par
exemple prévu contre moscou rui vous on
sait que c'est l'idée ensuite on de
savon en veut sanctionner non pas
tellement vous l'enlevez moi je pense
que avec madame merkel et monsieur
poutine
il faut discuter et quelque part on voit
qui est un sujet en temps réel il
n'intéresse pas du tout les américains
ils n'ont pas d'intérêt dans la zone et
ça les indiffère et donc nous il soit il
faut qu'on soit plus volontariste
essayer de mettre peut-être de rattraper
on vous écoute volontariste on est bon
il faut il faut tenir compte du rap rang
de venir souvent tout à la politique je
vous ai pas fait ce soir et
géostratégiques haut
nationale eh bien il ya le rapport de
force vous dites personne ne va mourir
pour kiev
et en même temps on a vu des ukrainiens
mourir pour l'europe
oui mais bien sûr cela il faut les
conforter seulement voilà quand on dit
et c'est logique c'est le message de
départ nous ne touchons pas intégrité
territoriale bien sûr après on voit
qu'elle est déjà atteinte avec ta crimée
et que de toute façon c'est irrémédiable
donc à ton cela et essayons de faire en
sorte que lié à trois une zone de
discussion russie ukraine union
européenne s est encore en rire je vais
vous dire à force de forcer sur le
partenariat et c'est pas tout à fait la
position de mes petits camarades à force
de passer de forcer sur le partenariat
uniquement avec l'union européenne
eh ben on va finir par la partition pour
le fossé qui rallie camarades parce
qu'ils ont compris mes amis ont suivi
son qui sont très oui oui on dit tout de
suite une europe oui ils ont raison
ça me voilà attention car attention
parce qu'à la réalité au delà des
slogans et du volontarisme
l'autre facette de l'europe l'enjeu
économique la france s'est fait
sèchement remettre sur les rails
apparemment sur les bons rails et même
la réduction à 3% de déficit en 2015 ça
reste l'objectif intangible a bien
souligné bruxelles
est-ce que selon vous manuel valls est
pris à revers après avoir affirmé qu'il
rejetait l'austérité qu'ils voulaient
donner des explications à bruxelles
on a signé le traité on a signé le
traité
moi le début de
devant les critiques à la politique
économique de françois hollande
cela remonte à ce moment là on avait dit
c'était d'ailleurs daniel cohn bendit
qui avait trouvé la formule brillante
comme souvent le traité merkozy donc
c'était le traité fait par madame merkel
monsieur sarkozy qui consiste à
effectivement à mettre tout le monde
dans une vision de réduction des
déficits et de la dette c'est pas
honteux rang soit d'ailleurs ça dépend
après quel niveau de fiscalité
c'était une défense alléguait toute
cette génération explique l'écologiste
moi je ne vous dis pas il faut raser
gratis il faut faire des déficits
on s'en fout faisant payer tout le monde
dépensant n'importe quoi ça n'a jamais
été le discours écologiste
après c'est savoir qui paye et au niveau
des impôts et qui voit les coupes
budgétaires et sur un poste
donc c'est ça le débat aujourd'hui on
est arrivé à une forme d'équivalence de
ce qu'on faisait avant sous la droite
c'est à dire la rgpp la révision
générale des changements des politiques
publiques et
j'ai déjà même oublié l'acronyme nouveau
qui doit être la réorganisation
administrative ou je ne sais quoi et le
sujet c'est de dire mais on va faire -3
à -4% partout ça n'a strictement aucun
sens on avait l'idée priorité à
l'éducation à la jeunesse à la justice à
la sécurité bon ben si ça doit se
manifester quand même un peu
budgétairement vous donc à l'aller nous
les écologistes nous sommes attachés et
et non je pense que en réalité et le
débat évidemment et sur les 3 % et je
pense quand même que c'est quand même
encore un mauvais message
on avait dit qu'on allait renégocier on
ne négocie pas on avait dit qu'on avait
pu volontariste et desserrer l'étau
d'austérité la rigueur on doit faire un
déplacement à berlin et puis boum on dit
bah en fait non on va faire ce que les
allemands et bruxelles veulent je suis
pas sûr ce soit un message qui renforce
le sentiment et la sympathie des
françaises et des français par rapport à
l'union européenne qui voit plus
maintenant comme un carcan une
contrainte comme une difficulté parce
que par rapport à une volonté ou un
enthousiasme ou quelque chose qui qui
provoque du bien et donc là on a une
vraie difficulté mais moi je faisais et
je le répète régulièrement
y compris au plus haut niveau de l'état
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire je comprends
le message vis-à-vis des entreprises
je ne veux pas comme le président comme
le premier ministre que le message
vis-à-vis des entreprises ce soit les
entreprises et font n'importe quoi on va
leur mettre des impôts dessus
ils ont besoin de deux contraintes
supplémentaires c'est pas ça le débat
moi je suis prêt à aider des entreprises
mais à côté de ça il faut qu'il y ait
établi non parce que le problème c'est
la question du volet économie c'est on
ne peut pas expliquer aux françaises et
aux français y compris dans la tradition
politique colbertiste qui est la nôtre
on va aider les entreprises et on va
serrer le kiki de des services publics
c'est pas possible c'est un message qui
est totalement quand il faudra bien
qu'on arrivera 3% et donc on en arrive
aussi aux débats la réforme fiscale
oui alors j'ai truc tu es dans tout il
faut réussir à expliquer qu'on tout à la
fois on veut aider les entreprises tout
à la fac on veut des services publics
feraient alors j'ai une dire cela il
faut des dépenses publiques j'ai une
question très l'avion ce public c'est
aussi la consommation présente reprise
et c'est aussi l'investissement des
infrastructures président en question
serait spiric sur une taxe à l'écotaxe
l'écotaxe savez que vous allez arriver
sur ségolène royal quel portefeuille
d'une écologie d'ailleurs qui aurait pu
vous rêvez vous revenir à vous les verts
jean vincent placé
à une vision toute personnelle
manifestement de certains sujets et sur
l'écotaxe et de la trouvent injuste pour
les camions français
est ce votre avis est-ce qu'il faut la
réserver aux camions aux étrangers je
veux dire je suis pour qu'on fasse de la
pédagogie bien sûr sur la fiscalité et
quand il y en a à faire la fiscalité
eh bien il faut en faire voilà on s'y
est pris comme des manches les pieds
chacun de ces expressions
mais ce qu'on aime sincèrement on arrive
on a redit qu'ils avaient sur l'île hier
d'un homme et je développe quand même
parce qu'on n'avait pas à parler d'éco
texte comme ça il ya 30 milliards
d'impôts fait par la droite
nous on arrive en fait 30 milliards déjà
on prend on aurait pu peut-être essayer
d'anticiper la trajectoire sur les cinq
ans en faire un peu la première année
dire que c'est juste et que ce sera la
dernière fois pour le quinquennat sera
était déjà plus intelligent c'est la
difficulté vu aujourd'hui le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires et te fait la
perception par les françaises et
français que c'est difficile la
pédagogie sur les impôts donc on a fait
un peu n'importe quoi
on arrive dans une séquence où je me
souviens que les économies lui-même
avait dit à williams a ras le bol
fiscale mais je vais quand même si parce
que il ya eu l'histoire ensuite des
bonnets rouges etc etc on vous dira pour
vous dire oui je comprend quelque part
la ministre de l'écologie par rapport
aux fêtes voyez c'était ça l'intérêt de
désistement d'être pédagogique de je
comprends que la ministre de l'ecologie
n'ai pas envie d'arriver avec sa
première action qui soit de la fiscalité
et de revenir sur la querelle de
l'écotaxe moi ça fait longtemps que je
dis à mes petites emma toujours les
mêmes les verts je redis mais attention
la fiscalité écologique ça paraît simple
même j'avais dit à nicolas hulot qui
comme le grand fondateur d'attac ce
carbone taxe carbone voyez il ya une
acceptabilité comme c'est que le royal
vous n'avez pas là l'école de linge et
punitive mais ce qu'ils m'ont réservé
les cotations
jeudi il faut et je passe à ce stade là
ce qui me paraît important c'est qu'il
faut dégager d'une façon ou d'une autre
les 800 millions d'euros qui étaient
destinés à voilà aux investissements de
l' agence française de la france on
tolère dégagements sont uniquement les
camions et dont j'ai moi j' que je veux
rien mais est aux frontières de la mon
problème à moi c'est de trouver bien
celui de ségolène royal elles ont fait
une proposition en tant qu'écologiste
quentin présent groupe parlementaire
c'est d'essayer pour la loi de finances
parce que le gouvernement propose nous
sommes encore un pays où le parlement
vote les budgets et la fiscalité
et donc il faut qu'on trouve en lien et
ségolène royal avec les premières pistes
qu'elle a indiqué par rapport aux 8 mai
par exemple j'avais dit essayons de
regarder les essieux c'est à dire que
techniquement pu les camions est gros et
plus on le taxe donc déjà il y avait
même pas de progressivité lors d'une
écoute est passé on écarter qu'il ya la
question des étrangers eux
par exemple moi j'ai une proposition c
d'exonérer si j'ose dire le cabotage
routier
c'est à dire que quand on fait 2 100 km
et 200 premiers kilomètres sont exonérés
voyez comme ça il est envoyé pour la
bretagne c'est très adapté on n'est pas
non plus plus idiots ils ont beaucoup
d'exonération et on peut essayer
d'étendre la discussion donc moi je
souhaite qu'on remette ça ce sera
effectivement le rôle et le fait très
bien moi je vous l'aï déjà dit mais je
suis très content que ségolène royal sur
la ministre de l'économie avance des
propositions l'ancienne candidate avec
son présidentielles du parti socialiste
et exerce cette responsabilité ça veut
dire l'importance que le président de la
république que le premier ministre ont
mis dans ce post d'avoir quelqu'un de
ces niveaux politiques de ce point
politique aurait fait mieux que vous non
mais écoutez moi je veux dire je suis
vraiment j'ai pas de prendre une
susceptibilité sur les écologistes ont
entendu que celle grosseur s'est très
bien entendus moi je dédie ce qui
m'importe c'est que l'écologie progresse
dans le pays si c'est ségolène royal qui
le fait tant mieux et je vais vous dire
notre rôle à nous parlementaires
écologistes et de l'ailé en faisant des
analyses des propositions et sur la
question de l'écotaxe et des
investissements vous m'avez entendu très
clairement il faut absolument et
s'assure le demande à ségolène royal
trouvez les 800 millions d'euros que les
collectivités locales les agglomérations
les plus communes à temps
leurs projets de transports collectifs
non mais c'est pas on attend aujourd'hui
pour financer des riens sûr on attend
pour des projets de tramway en temps y
compris pour nos héros hors d'île de
france et donc on a un vrai sujet là
c'est trouver ses 800 millions
si c'est sous les étrangers qui paye bon
c'est pas et peut-être un peu simpliste
au départ mais c'est un sujet
intéressant c'est vrai que quand elle
dit ségolène royal
il traverse la france il fallait même
pas décent chez nous même pas dans ta té
i pé fait quand même beaucoup non plus
il évite les autoroutes
il ya aussi un sujet autoroutes et moi
je suis en revanche pour qu'on essaye de
trouver une discussion y compris un peu
viril avec les sociétés d'eau comme
contre la privatisation je vois qui ça
rapporte et c'est pas le sujet du jour
jeudi je suis pas encore la
nationalisation parce que il semble pas
que ce soit la ligne du gouvernement
mais quelque part ça doit être un
argument et moi je souhaite que les
sociétés d'autoroutes
elle paye et papin celui qui prend les
autoroutes les sociétés de la drogue
comme un temps font des bénéfices
un l'absolu mais encore un terrain
d'entente avec ségolène royal assure
l'écotaxe apparemment ça peut se
débloquer entre vous sur ce sujet vous
pouvez trouver une entente alors on va
parler maintenant de la situation des
verts politiquement de votre jugement
sur le parti socialiste qui change de
tête ce mardi avec jean louis prévost de
la fp qui nous rejoint d'abord voyons
cette interrogation qui parcourt
certains de vos militants favorables et
nouvelle alliance non plus verts ps mais
vert rouge
le reportage de jérôme bonnard fin mars
à grenoble
le candidat écologiste gagne les
municipales le flux d'une alliance
encore var avec le parti de gauche de
jean luc mélenchon mais ce dernier rêve
de reproduire cette union aux prochaines
élections le refus des verts de faire
partie du gouvernement valls ne fait
qu'attiser cette envie certains
écologistes prônent cette nouvelle ligne
cette rupture par rapport à cette
alliance un petit peu trop trop serré
avec le parti socialiste qu'on a vécu
jusqu'à présent que c'est du passé
et pour ça il faut que en interne la
politique d'europe écologie les verts et
le courage d'être réaffirmée d'être
équilibrés vert
la gauche en quelque sorte c'est à dire
ceux qui pensent que l'austérité c'est
pas bien pour l'écologie et c'est pas
bien pour la population jacques boutault
n'aurait cependant pas été réélu maire
sans le soutien du parti socialiste
mais samedi dernier c'est du côté du
front de gauche qu'ils se ralliaient
pour la grande marche contre l'austérité
les drapeaux étaient plutôt rouges que
verts mais du côté du parti de gauche
ont les convaincus que les écologistes y
compris jean vincent placé céderont à la
tentation un jour ou l'autre le temps de
digérer ces deux années passées au
gouvernement
je le dis sans esprit polémique mais
quand vous avez quelques mois comme ça
quelques années au gouvernement que vous
avez dû quand même supporter une
politique était pas la vôtre europe et
il faut se désintoxiquer un peu donc et
je suis sûr que connaissant jean-vincent
à la fois ses convictions et puis son je
dirais son sens de certaines stratégies
je pense que lui aussi sport sera
abandonné le problème de savoir comment
nous devenons majoritaires pour les
idées que nous portons et c'est une
question il faudra peut-être leur poser
dans quelques mois à la tête du parti
écologiste il n'est officiellement pas
question d'alliance trop de divergences
notamment au niveau de l'europe
prudence aussi sur la transition
énergétique cher aux écologistes
un peu moins pour les communistes au
final ce sont les électeurs qui pourrait
renvoyer cette idée d'union aux
oubliettes le centre de gravité des
électeurs écologistes c'est plutôt la
droite du ps c'est pas la gauche du ps
donc il ya une distorsion entre
adhérents et électeurs
donc voilà je suis pas certain qu'il
soit que l'électeur de base soit aussi
enthousiaste pour mélenchon que ne
seraient certains adhérents voir
dirigeants d'europe écologie les verts
pour l'heure la priorité c'est l'europe
est un bon score des écologistes au
scrutin du 25 mai prochain pourrait
aussi remettre leur participation
gouvernementale au goût du jour
voilà janvier
bonsoir michel bonsoir vu en un sens oui
alors demain la direction du parti
communiste va rencontrer la direction
d'europe écologie les verts où il serait
peut-être est-ce que c'est
les prémices d'un premier rapprochement
non ce sont des réunions régulières
c'est ce que j'avais appris quand
j'étais losc international depuis
qu'emmanuel que c est à la tête du parti
il n'y avait pas une rencontre à ce
niveau là oui oui mais c'est notre
stratégie d'ailleurs qui est installée
en chine la prétention d'avoir été un
peu un aspirateur de ce qu'on appelle le
multilatéralisme dans les relations
partidaire à gauche c'est à dire le fait
d'avoir des relations avec le parti
socialiste et le parti communiste
français avec le parti radical de gauche
enfin l'ensemble des forces
constitutives les y compris d'ailleurs
le parti de gauche moi même d'ailleurs
j'ai eu une rencontre très amicale il ya
huit jours avec jean luc mélenchon
donc on discute on discutait du fonds
présents prix que jean luc mélenchon en
a beaucoup parlé de de l'ukraine pour
parler des questions internationales
c'est lui qui m'a convaincu d'être moins
radicale parce qu'elle lui dénonce des
néo-fascistes aguilo non non ces termes
là je ne les prends reprend pas mon
compte évidemment et j'ai conteste mais
c'est pas le sujet ce que s'ils
voulaient on peut repartir notre part et
d'ukraine riche mais sur cette
discussion qui est très importante
moi j'espère d'ailleurs que nous serons
capables à un moment je l'avais proposé
à quelques amis de la direction du parti
que nous fassions des assises la
transformation écologique et sociale en
particulier sur la question de la
transition énergétique
moi ça me ferait très plaisir que une
journée entière mutualité parce qu'on
avait fait ça là bas à l'époque
eh bien je suis incapable d'avoir
l'ensemble des forces politiques ps pc
pg et les syndicats et odf et monsieur
proglio et monsieur oursel et toulalan
ont parlé de l'énergie par exemple ça
c'est un pactole
juste avant il n'y a pas de fond ya une
pression d'une partie de vos militants
justement pour pour changer un peu
l'alliance que vous avez avec les
socialistes et pour la remplacer avec le
le front de gauche existe ils sont
engorgés par votre départ du
gouvernement
oui un oui c'est ses militants vous
allez leur dire non non vraiment c'est
du coup non c'est pas pour le meilleur
départ et d'une part on a des
divergences de fond heureusement qu
effectivement si on parle de l'ukraine
par exemple pour les élections
européennes on voit bien que on va pas
faire une alliance avec le parti
communiste français avec ce qu'on
appelle la gauche unitaire européenne
avec le pg sur les questions européennes
on va avoir des élections régionales le
parti de gauche jean-luc mélenchon il
jacobins et pour le supra d'une aide de
la nation française qui explique y
compris quasiment les langues régionales
c'est infâme donc manger j'enlève le
moins femme s'était pas ce n'était pas
intéressant dans une république une et
indivisible organique
on est rare en défendant les mêmes
sujets ce qui compte ce sont les débats
de fond est en réalité aujourd'hui
à partir du moment où nous avons y
compris incontestablement se choisit de
sortir du gouvernement la logique c'est
le rassemblement des écologistes c'est à
dire derrière nous delas coup fait aux
européennes de parler de l'europe par
l'hélico gide par les démocraties et aux
régionales la même manière et je peux
vous le dire là je pense que la
direction demandera aux à chacune des
régions françaises de faire des préparer
des rassemblement des écologistes des
listes autonomes pour les jeunes alors
je dis les choses
justement à grenoble eric vial a gagné
la mairie avec le parti de gauche c'est
un exemple à suivre pour vous si le
parti de gauche veut rejoindre les
listes écologistes dans ce rassemblement
autour de nos thématiques plus tôt sans
arriver avec des siennes et bien bien
ils seront le bienvenu après une
discussion sur le fond mais sur les
européennes donc je ferme à la cour je
ferme pas la porte mais avec un objectif
important pour vous oubliez européenne
vous l'avez rappelé est ce que vous
espérez arrivée devant le parti
socialiste
moi je suis être très franc si on fait
un résultat à deux chiffres je serais
très très heureux
nous avons un résultat à deux chiffres
s'assurait moins que lors des dernières
ont péri mais la dernière fois vous
savez de zellige déjà nous étions dans
l'opposition nationale nous étions
également dans un temps où la crise des
subprimes je n'avais pas tant impacter
sur l'économie mondiale en était dans
une période même de croissance et de
développement
1 juillet 2009 c'est quelque part vers
le pic d'une forme décennal de bonne
heure de bonheur occidentale l'économie
américaine marché bien la nôtre aussi
on arrive à une situation où il comprit
ont réussi à ré intéresser avec caisson
l'écologie tac avec les arrive fans
copenhague où la conférence sur le
dérèglement climatique
les américains et chinois disent
circulez ya plus rien à voir pendant
période de crise et donc on va continuer
à faire du productivisme comme avant et
les veaux et objectifs anti pollution ça
nous intéresse pas donc assez partir de
ce moment là déjà les sujets colons sont
plus dur à expliquer aux citoyens qui
sont dans cette crise et après les
régionales de 2010 le grenelle
environnement qui avait été initié par
jean-louis borloo et je le salue tac et
enterré avec la fameuse phrase de
sarkozy s'est dit lassé des colons
l'environnement ça commence à bien faire
donc c'était une autre circonstance et
2e aux circonstances on avait daniel
cohn bendit en tête de 10
c'est pas rien c'est un peu comme on
fait l'équipe mais c'est sans idéal ça
marche moins bien voilà on met mais
depuis le parti socialiste au pouvoir
est ce que pour vous ce serait
envisageable justement que vous soyez
devant le ps d'un côté stablement il ya
une compétition il y a des vases
communicants entre nos électorats à
cette élection européenne qui est
particulière parce que nous nous sommes
des passionnés d'europe
les écologistes incontestablement les
français ne sont - la participation est
toujours très très faible et c'est
compliqué d'animer le débat
voilà on va le voir au mois de mai on
voit que le 25 mai je le dis à nos
téléspectateurs
après trois ponts ça va être quand même
dur d'intéresser donc c'était c'est une
élection qui n'intéressent pas
malheureusement suffisamment donc nos
candidats vont essayer de pousser le
mouvement essaie de faire le maximum et
le fait que le parti socialiste soit en
difficulté aujourd'hui peut faire
qu'effectivement nous soyons réceptacle
d'un certain mécontentement mais je le
dis très clairement parce que je
l'analyse et cette manière là y compris
un peu comme
ce qu'a dit daniel bois le politologue
de fait la distance que nous avons prise
avec le gouvernement n'est pas forcément
susceptible de nous aider par rapport à
cet électorat ps déçu donc à yahia ce
débat là est par ailleurs je pense très
sincèrement que l'électorat extrême
gauche gauche de la gauche ne s'ajoutent
pas à l'électorat écologiste
la dynamique a été fait à grenoble est
une dynamique d'une part formidable
autour d'eric pieuvre qui est quelqu'un
de vraiment de solide peut-être
charismatique déjà c'est pas c'est une
figure qu'on ne peut pas transposer
comme ça ex nihilo et la réalité c'est
que il y avait une tradition historique
à grenoble a de valeur et 40 ans
d'accord mais pour les européennes bon
si c'est si on considère qu'il ya quand
même un risque important d'effondrement
du parti socialiste également de vous
annoncer que tel je ne mets à votre avis
est-ce que ça justifierait la formation
elle un remaniement ministériel après
son élection avec votre retour
le nouveau gouvernement a été constitué
il aida lyon c'est plutôt jeudi mais
plutôt des professionnels c'est plutôt
des gens solides moi je suis content de
l'arrivée donc de ségolène royal je suis
très content aussi je le salue mon ami
françois rebsamen qui était mon
homologue au groupe social et ça me
permet d'ailleurs de saluer l'arrivée de
didier guillaume le nouveau président du
groupe socialiste au sénat
donc il ya plutôt des gens solides gains
et ce gouvernement il faut qu'ils
travaillent à rendre à revenir à faire
le truc parce que j'ai excusé meur dont
vous nous avez fait pendant deux ans
qu'est ce que vous faites au
gouvernement je souffrais loin quand est
ce que vous vous revenez de
non c'est pas mérité
c'est justement est ce que ce
gouvernement va pouvoir enfin réussir en
trois ans ce qu'il n'a pas fait ce qu'on
attend de lui depuis deux ans j'attends
vos pour françois hollande c'est déjà ça
vaut beaucoup pour françois hollande
parce qu'effectivement quand même
l'échec est patent moi je ne suis quand
même pas le plus
le plus soucieux de de rajouter des
compliments à ce qui a été fait depuis
18 mois
tous les chèques et on baigne dans mes
l'échec est patent
c'est chez moi ils sont les françaises
et français ont durement sanctionné
globalement on va mener la même
politique donc ça va quand même pas être
facile
c'est aussi pour cela que cécile duflot
a souhaité sortir du gouvernement manuel
valls il met évidemment son talent
personnel dans la bataille autorités
énergie qualité et communicationnel en
bande ku en remarquable
donc est-ce que ça va avoir un effet
d'opinion malgré le fait qu'on n'ait pas
bougé de politique
on va voir est-ce qu'il est noir mon
objectif avec thé ecologist de pour les
six prochains mois à la prochaine année
s'est desserré justement d'essayer de
remettre plus de volontarisme économique
et social des est de faire en sorte que
la transition du générique arriver
peut-être on en parlera de faire en
sorte pour fasse enfin cette réforme
territoriale qui va plus tard mais
manuel vals justement vous en parler
alors à votre avis est-ce que c'est la
tour de la gauche pour 2010 est face à
un françois hollande
ça c'est le voyait comme un joker
prétendants mais on a jaugé pas de la
politique va pas l'échec patent de la
politique fiction et vous ne voudrez pas
de dire ça c'est ça qui me différencie
de vous vous êtes d'ailleurs de bons
analyses parfois même de deux bons
pronostiqueurs moi je suis pas dans
l'analyse et je ne suis pas seulement la
projection moi je suis un acteur de la
vie ma vie alors que les parlementaires
qui a vocation à aider le gouvernement
et si vous me posez la question un peu
plus factuelle de savoir quelle est
notre position rapport au gouvernement
je t'ai dit on ne participant plus mais
nous soutenons bien sûr alors maintenant
soutien sans participation mais je le
dis très clairement avec des
propositions à cracher sur les textes
regardez sur la loi dernière agricole et
bien s'entourer vêler nous allons la
voter ce soir nous ne sommes pas
satisfaits tout mais nous pensons grâce
à l'action de joël labbé de marie
christine blandin
nous pensons que nous avons eu des
avancées dans la discussion par rapport
à l'agroécologie et donc qu'on fait on
fait on va les cils du flat quitter le
gouvernement alors est ce que vous
considérez que maintenant elle a le
champ libre pour une candidature
vraiment offensive en 2017
mais alors là je vais vous dire
7 et ce y compris d'ailleurs les ans la
république qui ne penserait qu'à 2017
ce serait le plus sûr moyen du vainqueur
de rater le coup pour l'intéressé ait eu
ou et est aussi ça n'a pas de sens le
rapport à la situation du pays enfin moi
franchement concentrons nous sur le
travail en jeu c'est déjà assez lourd
françois hollande on assiste à un
tournant du quinquennat avec la fin du
président normal ont dit qu'ils le
françois hollande centralisée des six
nations c'est de plus en plus aux
nominations
est ce que ça vous inquiète non mais je
veux dire c'est je crois malheureusement
que c'est la logique du vème république
c'est que même quelqu'un de plutôt
démocrates attachés à la vie
parlementaire et très ouverts comme
françois hollande à la fin il est dans
la logique de l'institution et qu'est ce
que je peux lui reprocher à peine parce
que la réalité c'est qu'il faut changer
l'institution là c'est comme ça pendant
trois ans je penserai je pense que là il
ya effectivement il a mis beaucoup
d'autorité il a remanié à l'elysée il a
remanié au gouvernement il a remanié au
parti socialiste votre avis alors sur
jean christophe cambadélis puisque vous
avez salué l'arrivée de l'impressionner
le gouvernement ont félicité de celui
qui de l'arrivée de celui qui fut un
artisan de la gauche plurielle on s'en
souvient avec les mêmes gestes pas moi
je vais vous dire je suis connu pour ça
j'aime bien les gens qui sont
professionnels et l'a donc toutes les
strates on voit que intense il a
renforcé élections christophe cambadélis
c'est d'une part un stratège est
quelqu'un qui conceptualise les
questions du gauche française de façon
très intéressante il a fêté en papier de
blogs sur la question aujourd'hui de
l'extrême droite de la droite de
l'ensemble de dégoût gens avec lui si
quelqu'un de très intelligent
c'est quelqu'un de très intéressant
quelqu'un de très structuré et
d'organiser et je vais vous dire dans la
période ça peut pas faire de mal donc
moi j'ai pas mêler des affaires du parti
socialiste met d'accord on aura on aura
beaucoup de travail à paris jean
christophe cambadélis et on le fera
ensemble est-ce que vous pensez que
françois hollande pour éviter la
dissolution jusqu'à la fin de son
quinquennat
ça fait aussi un peu à côté fiction mais
on a quand même intérêt à voir des
résultats dans les quinze mois qui
viennent parce que la mer la pression
je la voir c'est la défiance vis-à-vis
du politique est très donc la tension
met en garde m la défiance est très
forte abstention c'est bien sûr le front
national et puis une violence une
violence des citoyens et aussi au delà
de la violence et de la colère à la
limite peut-être plus facile à
appréhender dans le dialogue
il ya la réalité aussi d'un look d'un
sentiment d'inutilité d'épaulé
d'impuissance d'après me sidère c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'à un moment il
faut quand même remettre
oui je vais vous dire des choses de la
puissance nom d'acteur politique donc
voilà vous êtes satisfait sur ce plan là
françois hollande a reçu des économistes
qui sont favorables à un smic un peu
réduit au rabais c'est ce que dit oui
également aujourd'hui le patron des
patrons monsieur gattaz une espèce de
smic inférieure donc à la norme pour
embaucher déjà une com est-ce que vous
réagissez vous si on veut la dissolution
où il faut faire ça oui c'est sûr non
mais c'est pas sérieux c'est il ya une
demande évidente de sécurité pas de
sécurité seulement d'ailleurs des biens
des personnes et de sécurité dans
bonjour 38 et de sécurité dans la santé
et il ya des besoins aussi de rassurer
les françaises et français
quant au pouvoir d'achat sur inter entre
eux c'est un terme qui plaît pas
tellement aux écolos parce que bon voilà
ça fait croissance consumérisme mais la
réalité du pouvoir d'achat des mieux les
plus défavorisés non mais c'est un vrai
sujet mais on dont c'est absurde voilà
je vais vous le dire c'est absurde c'est
ça fera trois fois plus nature de
dangereux trois fois plus de
manifestations que pour le cpe qui a
fait chuter villepin et voilà donc mais
manuel valls est quelqu'un de très
intelligent donc il évitera de tomber
dans dans ces impasses l'accord et man
veine en réalité je me fais un petit
couple est quand même sur un sujet qui
m'intéresse vraiment une chance que la
question compétitivité coût du travail
ça ne marche pas on va pas faire pour
moi trois mois cinq pour ça on va pas
être conquérir des marchés ce n'est pas
vrai dans un monde aujourd'hui ou au
brésil
selon le salarié c'est 400 euros en
chine c'est 250 au maroc etc
ça n'a aucun sens ça ne marche pas
avoir des produits à valeur ajoutée
c'est pour ça qu'on est bon sur la
gastronomie c'est pour ça qu'on est bon
sur le luxe même sur l'aéronautique
voyez vous dire celle écologistes qui le
dit on est bon sur l'aéronautique parce
qu'on n'aime plus value donc il faut
faire quelque chose on a de la plus
value et on peut même vendre y compris
cher parfois mais le truc la
compétitivité coût du travail
c'est une impasse aussi ça fait deux ans
que je dis ça et je le répète
malheureusement dans le vide mais on me
rendre à raison justifie jean-louis
alors là c'est arnaud arrive maintenant
et l'on va parler d'un sujet sur lequel
dont vous avez été précurseur jean
vincent placé la fin des départements
manuel valls l'annoncent et oui vous
vous l'a réclamée de longue date et vous
voilà isolé tous les deux sophie
normands après le non cumul des mandats
manuel valls ouvre un nouveau bras de
fer au sénat et annonce mercredi dernier
la suppression des départements d'ici à
droite gauche confondues les sénateurs
se sont aussitôt majoritairement élevé
contre la brutalité selon le de
l'annonce et faut-il faire disparaître
les départements
moi je suis plutôt un régionalisme et
j'hésite sur le fait d'aller si vite
alors qu' on n'a rien inventé pour faire
de la proximité de nos noms un peu de
temps pour mettre en place un dispositif
qui à gré tout le monde pour une bonne
partie des sénateurs le département
demeure un échelon essentiel la ou les
régions apparaissent parfois trop
éloignés des territoires ruraux autres
anicroche dans une assemblée sénatoriale
qui compte 10 % de président de conseil
général les élus se sentent dépossédés
de leurs prérogatives
les sénateurs sont élus au sein des
départements une première échelons donc
peut-être que l'on peut imaginer qu'à
moyen terme c'est le sénat qui est visé
à travers la suppression des
départements
c'est notre circonscription électorale
d'ailleurs nous n'avons pas de secteurs
comme les députés et là dessus je crois
que c'est très sensible
un seul groupe à apporter d'office son
soutien au projet le groupe écologiste
emmenée par jean vincent placé où je
pense qu'il n'a pas réfléchi je pense
qu'ils ne sais pas ce que c'est qu'un
département je pense que il n'a même
jamais siéger dans un conseil général et
par conséquent on peut pas raisonner
comme ça de façon je dirais abrupte à
l'emporte-pièce les écologistes se
disent tu l inverse en phase avec leur
temps
d'autres selon eux reste avec une
représentation de l'organisation
territoriale française héritée de la
révolution
seul contre tous nul doute en tout cas
que les écologistes seront les meilleurs
alliés du premier ministre au palais du
luxembourg
eux qui réclament la suppression des
départements de longue date
voilà perrine tarneaud jean vincent
placé toute nature de toutes natures ou
foulard et oui j'ai une partie de
personnel vous savez dans le vent ni
verbalement par les russes était lucide
on va parler la réforme territoriale
on l'a vu dans le sujet des élus
dénoncent le caractère brutal des
annonces de manuel valls est ce qu'il ya
un maître d'un problème de méthode sur
ce gros si l'internaute arrêtons ça fait
on en est mais je sais pas moi je ça
fait 20 ans je suis la vie politique
j'ai vu passer mais des stocks de
rapport est d'ailleurs tout à fait
honorable respectueux avec respectable
sur ces rapports
il ya eu le rapport raffarin moi j'avais
déjà salué sa reprend en gros ce qu'a
dit les élus ici c'est normal mais les
églises et les élus à un moment il veut
le sentais qu'on touche à rien voilà
c'est ça la réalité moi je suis ici j'ai
essayé mais respect pour mes collègues
sénateurs
le président bayle a fait un gros
travail sur les états généraux donc on
fait les états généraux ont fait des
rapports il y avait eu raffarin je me
souviens d'un rapport warsmann de
mémoire mais moi je j'apprends à ne plus
à ne pas défaire de critiques inutiles
mais ça fait par an ces débats là la
chose qui est clair c'est que depuis
1791 il ya des départements et à
l'époque on avait fait département
taillé pour que l'on puisse aller d'un
point à un autre dans une journée du
cheval vous voyez à peu près la vision
stratégique en termes de territoire
ensuite on avait fait des régions je me
souviens parce que voilà h et après des
séances politique qu'on avait fait deux
normandies parce qu'à l'époque valéry
giscard d'estaing avait deux fidèles
l'un à rouen et s'appelait jean lecanuet
et appliquent moi qui souvient de ça
mais bon michel
michel d'ornano à caen donc il fallait
faire deux dans man 10 donc vous voyez à
peu près comment les choses ont été
faites et on a fait à la française c'est
à dire les départements les 36000
communes les 26 régions on s'est dit on
va rajouter des agneaux parce que comme
on peut pas supprimer les communes
on va aller en plus ils s'affairent ce
nom parle on a les fameux syndicats
intercommunaux de l'eau des déchets
dresser des ordures de saab en voilà bon
ça me plaît beaucoup
voyez ce que c'est l'avis de leinua la
fin aussi agent 5 est ce que vous y
croyez à cette réforme du gouvernement
est gelé lui dit on a voté contre
c'est on à cette situation la banque
évidemment à faire des métropoles en
plus là mais on est quand même moment et
je suis très heureux moi parce que ce
que je dis
de plus au sénat depuis deux ans je dis
depuis deux cent le manuel valls l'a dit
pas mot pour mot mais dans sa
philosophie dans son discours de
politique générale donc pour les écolos
niche on est content on est content
après yann tiges et quand j'entends les
collègues qui siège dans fan depuis 30
ans dans sénateur et président français
généraux et qui dit ça on n'a pas été
assez concertée non mais jeudi on est là
on est on est chez les fous pour
produire son propre en font un moment
c'est pas possible
en effet un moment il faut écouter les
françaises et français les français et
françaises en ont marre sur les
questions de l'emploi voilà ça c'est
clair j'ai la prétention de penser
qu'ils sont assez attentifs bien plus
que nos élites avec et son écologie
notamment la vie quotidienne
moi je vois le débat pollution un réseau
ils ont l'efficacité ils veulent de
l'efficacité ils veulent que le
gouvernement soit efficace
ils veulent qu administrations centrales
se simplifient sassano débat moi je te
dis j'ai toujours dit au président et
pdg d'its la question administrations
centrales est essentielle
il faut plus de gens dans les
territoires particulièrement en
difficulté les territoires ruraux les
banlieues est pas tout le monde
concentré je suis désolé de faire un peu
le projet 10 mai dans le 7e
arrondissement
voilà il faut que les gens sortent c'est
pareil pour la police et leurs normes et
moi je suis rapporteur général
rapporteur spécial du budget sur la
police et gendarmerie on s'éteint un mal
conduit à chaque fois il ya énormément
de gens dans les guérites et c est pas
assez
dans les quartiers et là c'est la même
histoire des collectivités territoriales
les françaises et les français
ok c'est vrai que quand c'est chez eux
ils ont un phénomène nimby sts mais il
faut ré fait d'ailleurs il l'aura un
curseur d'un niveau de d'autorité et de
volonté réformatrice sur ce sujet parce
qu'on comptait sur vous oui mais ce que
cette volonté de réforme en tout cas est
ce que ça montre que le gouvernement
finalement a fait une croix sur le
maintien à gauche du sénat en septembre
prochain
non pas de raison mais d'évidence les
élections municipales et ont été perdus
ça va être plus difficile que prévu mais
ce n'est pas perdu pour le sénat on sait
le temps mais il faut faire les
élections maintenant je vais vous dire
je n'ai pas peur je pensais pas un seul
instant en 2011 que nous gagnerions bon
donc je pensais pas que nous gagnerions
et j'ai eu tout bon sens et 14 vous
allez perdre survenue elles veulent ça
j'avais envie de vous poser une question
un peu plus personnel sur son discours
de politique générale il a beaucoup
évoqué notamment la fin son parcours le
fils d'immigré
est ce que cette partie là de son
discours vous avez vu vous a
particulièrement touché sur lui de
barcelone et moi je suit séoul si j'ose
dire et il a été naturalisé beaucoup
plus tard que moi d'ailleurs je crois à
18 ou 20 ans et pour nous c'est la
passion de la france c'est c'est la
pression de la france de la république
de cette qu'il intègre celle qui donne
cette chance de parler français déjà moi
je ne parlais pas français
quand je suis arrivé à à sept ans et
demi je suis un peu comme ce que j'ai
dit j'ai toujours dit que j'étais petit
sept ans et demi et c'est
moi j'ai on aime cette france-là celle
qui justement faisait l'effort
d'intégrer d'apprendre les valeurs la
citoyenneté voilà c'est important est ce
que vous vous verriez vous aussi comme
lui premier ministre aux îles a beaucoup
d'avancé sur moi
on verra mais c'est pas le temps ça se
rattrape s'était pas non plus attention
c'est que je me savais oui on en parlera
j'ai compris mais non il faut aller vite
et que je suis d'une grande sérénité
voit pas de raison à la voilà pour plein
de raisons alors comme je le parle
d'excès de vitesse est vrai qu elle l
affaire des pv impayés de l'archange été
vu à la région ile-de-france alors ce
week-end sur un canal + vous avez été
accusé par la vice-présidente de la
région michèle sabban de ne pas avoir
tout réglé aujourd'hui jean paul huchon
le président de la région ile-de-france
a pris votre défense il assure que tout
est réglé au près la région alors
finalement qui a raison est ce que
michèle sabban est une menteuse
écoutez moi je vais vous dire les choses
sont simples d'ailleurs je me suis rendu
compte que de quelque chose parce que je
suis pas du tout dans beaucoup conduire
cette polémique me navre et y compris
certains de mes amis m'ont dit mehdi le
parce que ce sont des pv de
stationnement
voilà y'a pas je rate excès de vitesse
pas de je ne sais quoi ce sont des pv de
stationnement droit non mais je le dis
parce que j'ai compris qu'il y avait des
délires qui partait sur les réseaux
sociaux xterra ce sont des pv de
stationnement
c'est pas mal hein c'est une période où
je te le dis très tranquillement il ya
pas grand monde qui paient les pv dans
les collectivités territoriales parce
que il y avait des mauvaises habitudes
qui avaient laissé une grosse ardoise
oui je les dis je dis je n'excuse pas
d'ailleurs je décris les faits sont des
pv de sa seconde balle bêtement en bas
de chez moi trop souvent et c'était
avant 2009
voilà dans 85 ans et je ne vous a pas
échappé que je suis seul auquel on s'est
intéressé dans cette histoire c'est les
autres
manifestement ça intéresse personne un
petit travail dans quel peut-être
impossible
non non non voilà
j'ai reçu monsieur g beauty côté
investigations les réseaux sociaux donc
là les faits sont simples voilà ce sont
les faits on quand les seuls à chaque
fois qu'on m'a demandé de régler
j'ai réglé rubis sur l'ongle donc on
peut critiquer mais récemment a dit des
choses à la télévision je vais vous dire
aussi et vous le savez l'émission pré
enregistrés par la boîte de production
de monsieur lebon qui aimait chez
incrimine pas déjà incriminé ni
journalistes ni les journalistes ni ni
canal+ canal+ voilà c'est beaucoup de
respect pour y compris l'esprit canal où
j'ai pas de pros de deux sujets de
polémique
la corporation si j'ose dire ni avec
canal là sur le sujet de cette émission
si je suis désolé de vous le dire
c'était pas du journalisme si ce n'est
même pas c'est même pas du journaliste
politique c'est pas du journaliste est
finalement passé passé des
enregistrements hors plateau c'est comme
si vous passiez ce qu'on s'est dit oui
oppose après parce que le micro et là
c'est tout de même incroyable
jeudi c'est une première en france
c'était une première et donc avec ces
éléments là je suis désolé il faut quand
même les gens comprennent et bien j'ai
décidé avec mon conseil mon avocat
maître emmanuel pierrât de porter
plainte pour diffamation
et vous verrez que je ne mendie pas plus
alors pourquoi parce que la procédure
est ainsi donc on pantin pour x et
ensuite un juge d'instruction qui sera
saisie il fera son travail et je vais
vous dire c'est la première fois
dieu sait que j'ai lu et entendu des
mensonges totalement avérée dans
certains journaux du mercredi matin dans
les pages de dans certains échos et y
compris je le dis cette boîte de
production qui fait le cette émission je
suis pas comment la qualifier du
supplément sur canal et qui est la même
qui fait le petit journal
je peux vous dire que ça décrédibilise
totalement l'ensemble de votre
profession je suis désolé de vous le
dire voilà
une dernière fois vous étiez techer une
vente janvier vous vous étiez ces
personnes nous croyons pas ce que c'est
ils sont sept antennes mais c'est le
sachet ni les choses c'est un chéneau
bord merci maintenant on a compris que
tout est payé on à l'attestation
officiel de l'administration
merci les un peu touché par cette
affaire le temps de s'épancher à quoi
jean vincent placé
merci prochain preuve par trois ce sera
dans quinze jours maintenant notre
invité sera laurent wauquiez bonsoir est
très vite
et